a lot of your audience i mean it's wide
you said 18 to 25 year old men women too
yeah
i think would be amazingly interesting
if you sat down with a room of 80 year
olds yeah 80 year old men and women and
you know what these people are called in
america they're older than baby boobers
you know what they're called that
generation
traditionalists oh there you go okay
i'd be very uh curious to know what old
people would have to say about tate i
doubt that any of the older women or the
older men would try to be canceling tate
to be like yeah that's
everything we've ever known but this is
the thing that's interesting because the
feminist narrative when i say things
like the male pilot for example the
feminist narrative is that i'm a
controlling man who wants control over
women the actual truth is i'm a
protective man who wants to protect and
being a man in a position of protecting
is not always a good thing i feel
indebted and have a duty to myself and
my honor meaning that if i'm walking
down the street with a beautiful woman
and three men want to attack her i have
to risk my life now i can't live my life
letting my wife get gang raped on a
[ __ ] street and running away i can't
take it as a man so i have to now die
i have to die or try i have no choice so
but that's my duty but they'll they'll
ignore that part they'll ignore the part
where i risk my life right and they'll
say oh but you just want to be
controlling misogynistic no no i have a
duty to protect i'm calm or under
pressure because i've been in more
unfortunate situations i've had more
trauma in my life which has trained me
to be more calm under pressure i would
hate to meet a woman who's been through
as much trauma as i have that's not the
kind of
that wouldn't make her a good woman i
don't think women need trauma on that
level i don't want women who've been
stabbed there's no need for that but i
have been through it so i think that in
my experience extrapolation that men who
are successful a lot of them have been
through enough for me to trust them more
in a high pressure situation and like i
said this comes with massive
responsibility this comes with massive
detriments and downsides right and the
feminists like no you're controlling the
it's not about patrolling it's about
duty there was no feminist on the
titanic then then men can die there's no
feminists to this day in ukraine
the ukrainian women can leave you'll see
them partying in warsaw and prague
ukrainian men can't leave the country
they're dying in a ditch
they have to stay and fight not a single
feminist is demanding that the women
stay and fight not a single one they
don't give a [ __ ] when it turns real
once it turns hot then it's
straight to what do you want sandwich
sure well what do you understand sir
what do you need then it all goes back
the closer you are to the real world the
closer people instantly get into their
gender roles because otherwise they get
annihilated in real time that's another
thing i said when i was getting called
misogynistic and i was arguing with
feminists i said traditionally men are
leaders
and in ancient societies men were in
charge
that's because men are oppressive you've
impressed us forever that's their
narrative their narratives that we've
impressed women forever i said no
we've protected and provided you forever
the reason we are leaders is because if
we align with our gender roles
a man's more likely to lead and that
gives us a more competitive chance
in the olden world where all the empires
were currently fighting if you're not as
competitive as possible you're going to
be annihilated i would argue that
perhaps there were some civilizations
where women were in charge but we don't
know who they are and we can't discuss
their history because they were [ __ ]
annihilated in real time by the ones
where the men were in charge because you
are hyper competitive you're at your
optimum when men are in charge that's
just the optimum of the gender roles
that's the way it works i don't believe
we've been oppressing you since the dawn
of human time i disagree i believe we've
been working hard protecting providing
for you if men were truly oppressive to
women why don't we send the women to war
women on women it's fair right we could
send all the women to war ukraine all
the women to war in russia they can die
and we can sit and we can chill we go to
warsaw and drink vodka we don't do that
the men of ukraine and the men of russia
are dying to protect their women and
then they want to sit and say that we're
bad
it's a it's a completely skewed world
view whenever they come along and say
that we're oppressive and that we have
the most money and all this [ __ ]
it's a lie we are going out of our way
and giving up our lives to protect and
provide
and this is where it comes to some of
the other things that they said against
me i've said
a man
doesn't a man has a degree of authority
over something he has responsibility for
they took this and they used it and said
that i think that men have authority
over women it's not what i said i said
if i have responsibility for something i
must have a degree of authority over
that thing
if i have a uh
a car if it for it to be parked in the
wrong place or for me to drive too fast
whatever whatever for me to be
responsible for the actions of that car
it must be my car if it's parked in the
wrong place but it's not mine and i'm
not allowed to drive it then i'm not
held accountable for me to be
accountable i have to have
responsibility by extension that gives
me a degree of authority so what i was
saying is if a woman comes to me and
lives with me and i pay the bills and
she travels the world with me and she
flies on jets and we go to boats and
she's taken care of
i'm responsible for her safety if we
walk the street at night i ensure her
life is in perfect order i have a degree
of authority where i can say you're not
going to go out at night by yourself
it's dangerous or we're not going to go
to this country right now it's dangerous
that's a degree of authority that i have
that comes with my responsibility from a
protective manner that does not mean i
am oppressive that does not mean i'm
misogynistic it just means that
responsibility and accountability are
linked and they can't be decoupled
a captain goes down with the ship
because the captain is responsible for
what happens on the ship if the captain
gives orders and everyone ignores him
then he doesn't go down with the ship
does he he is he has authority because
he is responsible two things are the
same and once again people have
misunderstood what i said that's what i
said in a healthy relationship perhaps
in my relationships i'll talk from a
personal perspective so then i can't be
attacked in my relationships i am
responsible for the emotional security
and for the physical security and the
fiscal responsibility the fiscal
security of any woman i'm with and by
extension i have a degree of authority
over her to make sure that we as a
couple proceed and progress in the best
possible way it's not going to be 50 50
if i'm in charge of the most important
things it's gonna be like listen i love
you very much i respect what you're
saying and you're totally right about
this but on this one point i'm sorry i'm
gonna be the man we're doing it this way
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to watch the entire podcast click over
here and if you want to be connected
with experts influencers such as
kiyosaki tate connolly palminteri myself
and others download the app minect where
you get a chance to connect with these
folks by the minute you get to buy the
minute or have face times with them 15
minutes ask them any questions you may
want to have download the admin act and
start connecting with influencers and
experts today
[Music]